- [Narrator] One of Hollywood's
recent breakout stars
isn't some up-and-coming actor.
Actually, he isn't even human.
It's this little guy, Baby Yoda,
or that's what fans named
the child-like alien
from the hit Disney+
show, The Mandalorian.
Instantly meme-able, the
little green character
helped make Disney's new show
and its new streaming
platform a smash hit.
Since launching in November 2019,
Disney+ has surged to the upper echelon
of the crowded streaming ranks,
with 37 million subscribers in the US
and over 86 million globally.
It's success has marked
a bright spot for Disney,
a company that has lost
a little bit of magic.
In The Mandalorian,
characters go to great lengths
and take a few risks
to keep Baby Yoda safe.
(dramatic music)
And in many ways, Disney
has made similar moves
to help its nascent
streaming platform thrive.
Baby Yoda might have been a new character,
but the universe he lives
in wasn't new at all.
Disney owns the Star Wars franchise.
It's one of the many well-known brands
the company packed into its
Disney+ streaming catalog.
WSJ's Eric Schwartzel has been
following Disney+'s growth.
- The Mandalorian has been
the breakout hit of Disney+
and it's no surprise because it combines
a known entity, the Star Wars universe,
arguably the most successful
franchise in Hollywood history,
with a new storyline that you can only see
and explore on Disney+.
- [Narrator] Disney+ offered 500 films
and over 7,500 TV episodes at launch.
- They had this stable of brands
that they could already draw on.
Plus, they had movies and characters
that people wanted to
watch again and again.
So if Disney+ became the exclusive home
of the Iron Man movies and
the Finding Nemo movies,
that was already a built-in advantage.
Then they were able to use
those brands and characters
to make sequels and
reboots that become events
on the service and give
them this perfect bridge
of new material using
older familiar characters.
- [Narrator] This helped
garner 10 million subscribers
on its first day, with The Mandalorian
driving buzz and aclaim.
This overnight success couldn't have come
at a better time for Disney.
Even before the pandemic,
investors had questioned
Disney's longterm growth potential.
Disney+ was viewed as a critical venture
to help the company capitalize
on digital entertainment,
but with so many streaming
options crowding the space,
the platform wasn't a surefire bet.
Here's former Disney CEO and
current executive chairman
Bob Iger speaking to WSJ in 2019.
- This is a dramatic shift
in the way people consume
entertainment and information.
Your business is going
through the same thing.
And it requires an
immediate shift in strategy
in order to stay healthy,
in order to thrive.
- Investors were looking
at companies like Netflix
and seeing those as companies
where there was a lot of growth,
whereas Disney, despite
ruling the box office
and having theme parks that
had to turn people away
they were so popular, had a
major issue with cord cutting.
- [Narrator] This cord
cutting was felt most
by Disney-owned cable network, ESPN.
And as cable subscriptions fell,
Disney's stock price became more volatile.
- Wall Street wanted to see a strategy
for growth and a strategy for the future.
And that is what led
executives to conceive
of Disney+ and launch it in 2019.
So when the pandemic hit with
Disney shuttering theme parks
and no theaters open to screen movies,
its share price took a dive.
With people staying home revenue shrunk
and Disney+ quickly became more important
to the company's bottom line.
- Without those traditional
revenue streams,
Disney+ was leaned on even harder
as a place to look to for investors
as something that might
keep the company afloat.
And frankly it has worked incredibly well.
- [Narrator] So well that Disney announced
a massive restructuring of the company,
positioning streaming as a top priority.
- Essentially, what we want to do is
separate out the folks who
make our wonderful content
based on tremendous franchises
from the decision-making
in terms of where the prioritization is,
in terms of how it gets
commercialized into the marketplace.
- [Narrator] This included
redirecting high-profile releases
like Hamilton and Mulan from
theaters onto its platform.
♪ Alexander Hamilton ♪
♪ My name is Alexander Hamilton ♪
- They reorganized the company in a way
such that there is now
an almost agnosticism
about where a movie or TV show will run.
It is more about creating that show,
building that programming,
and then deciding
would this be best in a theater?
Would this be best on a TV network?
Would this be best on Disney+?
And increasingly Disney+
is the preferred option.
- [Narrator] This strategy seems
to have energized Wall Street.
Despite posting two consecutive
quarters of losses in 2020,
including losing over $2
billion in its park division,
Disney's stock price has rebounded.
In November it announced plans to lay off
32,000 employees by March, 2021,
mostly in its parks division.
It also said it would be
suspending its January dividend
to invest more heavily in streaming.
On top of this Disney+ set of projection
of 260 million subscribers by 2024.
But experts question how realistic
this forecast actually is.
A Disney spokesperson said in a statement
that with a rapidly expanding pipeline
of exceptional original
programming in the works
the company believes it will significantly
expand its global subscriber base.
- What they're trying
to do now is figure out
what they can do in terms of pricing
and also what they can do in
terms of international growth,
because that is where a lot
of the new subscribers are
going to be coming from.
There are some challenges ahead.
For one, it remains an
incredibly competitive landscape
and no one really knows yet
how many streaming services
the average consumer might
want to subscribe to.
And the other question
becomes what is temporary
and what is permanent
when it comes to the way
viewing habits have changed
during the pandemic.
- [Narrator] Questions
like these will test
whether Disney can navigate
a post-coronavirus business landscape.
And if Disney+ can not
only be the most magical,
but also the most
streamable place on earth.